okay so the leaks for chapter 285 of my
academia have just come out and i gotta
say this chapter may have altered the
course of this series forever
it raises so many questions about the
fate of baccago
not to mention the true nature of one
for all and also whether deku will ever
use his arms again
in this video i'll be taking you through
most of the elite panels
however make sure you subscribe because
as usual i'll be doing a detailed
breakdown of the official chapter
when that comes out okay so everything
kicks off with deku flashing back
to after his fight with muscular in
which the doctor explicitly told him
that he could lose control of his arms
if he keeps getting injured like that
to be more specific midoriya was told
that his ligaments had already
deteriorated
really badly and his medical charts made
it look like a bomb had exploded inside
him
bearing that in mind we see midoriya in
the present day going
full kamikaze and just unleashing
several consecutive smashes on sugouraki
we get the classic detroit smash as well
as the wyoming smash which we saw for
the first time a few chapters ago
and also a texas smash for good measure
now at the end of chapter 284 izuku did
say that he didn't care what happened to
him
but i'm gonna be honest i personally
didn't think he would take it this far
shigaraki acknowledges that the damage
that deku is is dealing right now
is surpassing what his regeneration is
capable of
according to the unofficial translation
shiguraki tells midoriya
that he's getting in the way of his evil
dreams to which deku replies
that's the reason i have this power we
see deku flinging shigeraki around with
black whip with his left arm
and then his right arm just looks
wrecked beyond words like honestly
when you see the official translations
and the official chapter you'll just
his arm's not being used again unless
unless every pulls through
or unless he gets a robotic arm or
something like he's just not going to be
using this thing anytime soon
back down on the ground bakugou hatches
a solid plan to finish shigaraki off
by using his explosions to bring
endeavour into the sky
at which point the number one hero will
unleash his prominence burn which
obviously he used to finish off the nomu
as well
according to endeavor his highest
firepower will eliminate shigaraki
and so bakugou requests that shoto uses
his ice to keep his dad cooled down
until the very last minute as the three
of them jet off into the sky
you can see the fear in rock clock's
eyes because as we all know rock glock
he's all about protecting the youth
keeping the kids away from danger and
right now from his perspective
it must seem like the kids are actively
trying to die
bakugou pulls endeavor and shoto towards
the sky
and the number one says that once he
gets closer to shigaraki
the two students should leave so that
they aren't caught in the blast radius
he also has a plan for deku to avoid the
blast as well because i don't think he
wants to kill a student
but we'll get to that in a bit whilst
this is happening
we get a brief flashback at this moment
tobacco goes discussion with all might
in the gym
and yeah again all might says that there
are things he can't confirm about one
for all
which is along the lines of what he said
in the last chapter as well it then
flashes back to a different time
and according to the rough translations
bakugou is essentially saying that
one for all is the same as all for one
because it derives from afo himself
if this wording is accurate then i
wonder if this is hirokoshi's subtle way
of foreshadowing that one fool may have
the power to take quirks
like all for one after all in my opinion
at least
by the end of this series shigaraki
either has to be dead or quirkless like
i just don't see
any other path beyond those two options
so maybe if deku one day has the power
to
take quirks then you know that could
that can make things quite interesting
between the two of them
as they approach shigaraki in the
present day endeavour jets off ahead of
bakugou and shoto
and grabs shigaraki by the arms in a way
that prevents the villain from decaying
him
at this point deku is still holding onto
shiguraki with a black whip from a
distance
and endeavor just yells at him to stay
back before unleashing
a close-range prominence burn which you
know is going to fry sugaraki
we can see that shige is properly
burning up but then something super
weird happens
as the consciousness of all for one
appears yet again in shiguraki's mind
and says lend me your body little
brother
shigaraki then activates force quirk
activation
with the tentacles forcefully stabbing
endeavour through the torso
causing him to spit out blood at this
point shiguraki does not even look human
because endeavours basically burned off
all of his skin
and these tentacles on his back that
almost reminds me of doctor octopus from
spider-man
and they head straight towards deku i
assume the intention is that
once the tentacles touch deku they can
forcefully activate his quark and then
initiate the transfer
of one for all to shigaraki what i
didn't understand though
was why all for one's consciousness was
saying lend me your body little brother
like
that kind of implies that all of this is
just some elaborate plot by all for one
to get a new body but at the same time
couldn't dr garaki just make him a new
body in the same way he did for
shigaraki
i don't know let me know your thoughts
down below what what is all for one
trying to achieve right now
the chapter ends with bakago's most
heroic moment in the series to date
which is the reason this chapter is
literally called bakago rising
as the forced quirk activation heads
towards deku
bakugo's body moves without hesitation
and his explosions propel him towards
midoriya
his life essentially flashes before his
eyes as we see a bunch of flashbacks
over the years
including him and deku in middle school
together and their fight at ua
and also when they were on punishment
together as well
when we cast our minds back to one of
the earlier chapters
we saw that at the beginning of the war
bakugo's mom was like reading a picture
of it like a memory book
of bakago which is obviously a massive
death flag
and now in this moment he's looking back
at previous moments in his life with
deku
i mean major death flags everywhere
in a last-ditch attempt to save his
friend he pushes deku out the way
and then takes the full force of
shigeraki as these force quirk
activation tentacles
pierce through his stomach and shoulder
and then come out on the other side of
his body
this is a serious serious injury
and i find it unlikely that horikoshi
would kill off bakago this early
but after seeing this panel i don't
think anyone could say it's impossible
especially with what i just mentioned in
this moment
bakugou did exactly what all might said
makes a hero great
in that his body moved without thinking
to save the life of another person
just as deku tried to do for him all
that time ago
bakugou is now repaying him and in many
ways you could say this is bakugo coming
full circle in the last chapter it was
basically confirmed that
by him helping deku to master his new
quirks that's basically his way of
saying
sorry for bullying you and now in this
chapter he takes the
full force of of this crazy villain
clearly
bakugou his character is evolving a lot
right now and i don't think that right
now is the time to kill him
just as he's becoming this essentially
almost like a new person
but with that said that was everything i
had for this spoiler overview
like i said a million times i'll be
doing the breakdown officially on sunday
or monday
so be sure to turn on notifications and
stick around for that
and until the next one peace out